-Billy, you are up.
Come pull the mic.
Let's see what game you get,
please.
-Let me pull this mic.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God. I'mma sit.
-Whoo!
-You were awesome.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Musical Genre Challenge!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay!
-♪ Musical Genre Challenge ♪
-Now, here's how this works.
You're gonna get a song title
and a totally different
musical genre,
then you have to sing that song
in that style.
-Okay.
-Let's see what you get.
-"Stronger," Kelly Clarkson.
Ooh!
-Oh, my goodness!
-Ooh, I kinda like this!
-Not fair!
-I kinda like this combination.
-That's not fair.
-Gospel is my wheelhouse.
-I'm just gonna leave.
-Yes!
-Oh!
-Billy's over there...
-Y'all ready to go to church?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I am, actually.
I'm ready. I'm ready.
-Oh, my God.
-Turn to your neighbor and say,
"Are you ready to go to church?"
-Are you ready to go to church?
-Oh, man, I'm ready. I'm ready.
-♪ You know the bed
feels warmer ♪
♪ Sleepin' here alone ♪
♪ You know I dream in color ♪
♪ And I do the things I want ♪
♪ You think you got
the best of me ♪
♪ Think you have had
the last laugh ♪
♪ Bet you think that
everything good is gone ♪
♪ You think you left me
broken down ♪
♪ Think that I'll come ♪
♪ Running back ♪
-Yeah!
-♪ But, baby,
you don't know me ♪
♪ 'Cause you're dead wrong ♪
♪ What doesn't kill you
makes you stronger ♪
♪ Stand a little taller ♪
♪ Doesn't mean I'm lonely
when I'm alone ♪
♪ What doesn't kill you
makes a fighter ♪
-♪ Ohhhh ♪
-♪ Footsteps even lighter ♪
♪ Doesn't mean I'm over ♪
-What is happening?!
-♪ Because you're gone ♪
♪ Oh, what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger, stronger ♪
♪ Oh, oh, makes you stronger ♪
♪ I'm, I'm so much stronger ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪ Stro-o-o-o-onger ♪
♪ Ohhh, baby, ay ♪
♪ Just me, myself, and I ♪
-♪ Ahhhhh ♪
Whoo!
-[ Vocalizing ]
♪ Yeaaaaaaah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah!
-You know.
-Get outta here. Get outta here.
-You can't take
the church out of me.